das ist eine summe die sich arbeiten
lässt ja ich denke damit lässt sich
sicher was auf die beine stellen
allerdings koppelt kleiner für die
großen events sind damit trotzdem nicht
drin
es geht bei diesen events auch nicht nur
um irgendwelche hochgebirge netz die
künstler die sollen trotz ihrer
popularität authentisch und vor allem
ehrlich rüber kommen wie dungeon
einzuholen
lukas entspann dich es war nicht meine
idee mein freund für diese kampagne
einzusetzen
hey ich mag kreative auseinandersetzung
aber können wir vielleicht zu tagen
meines wissens ist roh ausgebildeter
tontechniker und hat danach ein
instrument studiert richtig gut ja schon
genau deswegen sind er und seine band
die ideale besetzung für bilden fürs
leben darüber lässt sich nicht streiten
ich möchte nur vermeiden dass ein
falscher eindruck wegen meiner privaten
beziehung zu ihm entsteht vertrauen mir
das wird nicht passieren das verspreche
ich dir nun gut
somit sind die rahmenbedingungen klar
dann können wir jetzt anfangen die
einzelnen posten zu vergeben
ja ich fühle mich heute haben das
shooting damit wir das thema
schnellstens abhaken können dann lass
uns mal den vertrag angehen
lukas heißt eine minute sonst gerne ich
habe eigentlich nur ganz kurz ich würde
gerne mit ihr über die charity event
sprechen
hast du doch organisiert und abgerechnet
wir müssen das vertagen ich habe dafür
echt keinen kopf entschuldige hochzeit
von catherine sicher
bis später
ich muss jetzt noch was erledigen und
dann treffe ich mich mit laser zu hause
kennt freut mich sehr ehrlich zu ihm
sitze ich mit ihm zusammen sagt die
wahrheit
banken die pid für euch und baby da du
kannst auf uns zählen mädchen
meinst du etwas
es ist wirklich alles in ordnung danke
ich weiß nur gerade nicht nur der kauf
steht kalte milch jungen zwei stück zu
können
was für eine überraschung
schön dass du weißt ja eigentlich bin
ich wegen dieser hier bist du da die
arbeit der müsste jeden moment nach
hause kommen wenn du magst kannst du
gerne hier auf ihn warten
ich weiß noch nicht
ich wollte mich an einen tisch setzen
willst du auch einen geht es um die
sache mit lauter ich schätze mal weiß
bescheid
ja ich weiß bescheid reese hat sich
umeinander verplappert da wird ziemlich
wütend ich wollte wissen ob alles wieder
in ordnung ist
das gibt sich bestimmt wieder aber sag
mal wie geht es dir dann stehst du mal
wieder im trend auf der bühne
du warst du schnell weg von der
vernissage
george ist deswegen franziska sie weiß
nichts von uns ich habe jetzt ja nicht
erzählt weil ich nicht will dass sie von
uns für beziehungen gefährden
ich habe mich so sehr gemobbt
ich wollte ich einfach vergessen